this weekend building the leaderboard
project so last week I designed it and
this weekend trying to implement it
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
well start the project with the layout
and later we'll move the components and
to react component it shouldn't take
much longer because we'll be like copy
paste later to react confidence
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's Friday in the email this is how the
app looks right now I'll say it's ready
and ready to go when it comes for the
situation the default tab is less 40
days in the user can change the dock to
all times where the total amount of
points is the priority the list needs a
moment to load that's why I introduce
the interest in here with loading the
leaders graphics the app is built with
bootstrap partially with flexbox and of
course with reactants us according to
the requirements I introduced a few
changes regarding the previous design
they were usually about the position
where something stores or about the font
sizes for example here this free code
camp leaders headline is much bigger
than anda in the design and also when we
talk about wider screens in order to
keep the visual hierarchy better I also
made the badges and the username bigger
the app is accessible from the keyboard
and you can access each unfilled camp
leader from here and go to the your free
code camp profile the previous apps that
i did with the genius web either bigger
like github battle that was done with
[ __ ] or smaller as a result
here I have to stop her and the thing
how to do it helps implemented what's
established do I really need web back
and things like that it was really
problematic because for a moment I
didn't know only what to do and then I
started copying and pasting from the
previous apps and bring it step-by-step
checking if and when I copied wax and
did and so that's how I had that that's
why I defeated this problem this was a
really a problematic woman this way
because I didn't know what to do for a
moment and give motivation falls down
then when it started working it rise up
again next week I'm going to start in
love it will be their recipe box it is
quite a backup so probably it will take
me longer done and we do it if I want to
really polish it um when I started this
week i also found very interesting
resource about java split about vanilla
JavaScript I will share with also in the
video description below if the serious
called JavaScript parity which is about
50 tasks and felt solutions to these
tasks um and this is the challenge to
build 30 new project with vanilla
JavaScript all of them should be built
with vanilla JavaScript so no frameworks
and you have to deal with them on your
own just only with gay ass that's why it
can be pretty challenging a pretty fun
and i already have to find time to look
into it
so the project is done you can see it as
the one who does / leaderboard i will
put the link in the video description
below keep on doing and see you next
week
[Music]
you